[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
live coverage of the 2023 national
championships we have a very special
guest in studio Marina tobina Marina
thank you sir you thank you so much are
an Emmy award-winning a costume designer
and an
entrepreneur welcome welcome welcome
we're not worthy this is really really
really great and uh Kate I mean you're a
big fan because of her Association maras
with Taylor Swift yes you work with
Taylor Swift Nicki Minaj Juliet Lewis
that's amazing how did you come to to
work with these artists it's been a very
long journey um I started out heavily
getting involved with the industry right
after I graduated college I went to the
Fashion Institute of Designing
merchandising in LA and Dove straight
into fashion my last quarter at the
school so I formed my own brand had my
own company um working with a lot of
stylist um just pretty much doing a lot
of the footwork and paying the dues and
working for free and getting my products
out there my designs out there and it
kind of started falling into the hands
of the right stylist and it started with
editorial work and then slowly moved
into music and the chess connections
tell us about those uh Marina um I I
think for me kind of
happened
um very organically I would say in my
career wasn't something that was ever
planned it just happened to be the
multiple performances were geared around
that creative uh my first chess
performance was I used a character when
we did um the Grammy performance for
Taylor Swift I believe was
2012 um that was the opening performance
yes wow so that was my first take on um
utilizing chess as part of costumes and
I did a night costume that was very
beautiful it was a vintage Circus theme
and I did almost like this beautiful
ballerina where her entire skirt was the
game wow and then I was the costume
designer for So You Think You Can Dance
and one of our main group performances
was also around a chess game and then
Katy Perry happen moving on to that
everybody knows about the halftime Super
b b show just incredible design
incredible kind of seeing the chest look
at that seeing it here taking me back to
my
yes it feels like yesterday today right
2015 the time goes by so fast8 years and
uh are you always going around the world
then and going through all of these
different shows and put bringing your
costumes how does that work um I mean
every performance every job is very
different I have been very fortunate um
to be able to travel the world for my
work I've worked on some incredible
opportunities incredible artists of of
course most of the time we see airports
and the venues um we relate to that ch
ch is the hotel right so I know where
all the venues are and I know where all
the airports are um but it has been a
blessing in my career to truly be able
to say that throughout the 20 years that
I have been designing I truly have been
able to see the world through the eyes
of an artist so it's been pretty
incredible I'm curious so you designed a
lot of Chess theme costumes what's your
relationship with chess I know you've
been born in MOS but then you moved to
us do you have a chess culture do you
play chess I I my dad um taught me when
I was very young I believe at 5 years
old was the first time that played the
game and then I remember being seven or
eight years old that we went to summer
camp U my dad was a wrestling coach so
every summer we went to all the
different camps and I always traveled
with him and one hotel I remember had a
giant chessboard table and that was kind
of our thing every morning was to go out
and play chess and that's how that came
into my life um and then I didn't even
realize until we started seeing all
these repetitive materials of wow I've
Incorporated a lot of Chess into my
designs and I think maybe subconsciously
somewhere it was always that I knew how
to play I knew what the game has taught
me I think it's it wasn't just a game
for me because I always played it for
fun you know so it wasn't ever a
professional take on it but the fact you
had the love for chess since beginning
yes and I think it helped me a lot um I
can understand why you know the Russian
culture is very much about chess games
and I I think having it at such a young
age of experience in my life it taught
me how to navigate through my life and I
do things somewhere now that I'm seeing
all the correlations that it did help me
as a designer as well as a chess
Grandmaster myself one of the things uh
I always is look for I see it everywhere
whether it be in commercials whether it
be in marketing whether it be in art
they use the chess themes everywhere you
have a big lecture coming up tomorrow
for those of people who are in the St
Louis area at the uh Washington
University uh tell our audience about
that how they can get tickets how they
can join you and what are you going to
talk about tomorrow well I'm very
excited um for the opportunity to be
able to share my journey and also um
integrate what chess means to me in my
work and how it's been seen throughout
the years and I think tomorrow is just
going to be an open raw conversation
about all the experiences that I've had
I like that rock conversation let's
rock just a real transpara of
conversation of what a fact that might
have had on my career that I'm just now
recognizing at the same time walk the
students through my journey um and see
what's possible like what was the real
life experiences like and share that
with everybody and hopefully inspire
exciting and again that's tomorrow what
time University of uh of Washington it's
3M 3 p.m. yes cuz I'm planning to be
there I love I have to say you know I
like for example St L CH CFE it's all
about educating about a game of chess
even young very young children and a lot
of players or parents or think people
think uh that it's about creating Grand
Masters or just having really strong
players but it's really just to
introduce the game and to kind of build
that laugh for the game and maybe to
have new award-winning you know costume
designers not necessarily Grand Masters
exactly but it's also so important for
your mind I think for me looking back
and and kind of knowing that at a young
age I was placed in front of this game
where I had to use my mind I had to sit
back and figure out how to navigate
through a board later on in life that
that's exactly what I'm doing now I'm
navigating my career around certain
decision- making artistic calls and so
to me it's like the two and two really
do go go together so it's an honor and a
privilege to be here and also at the
same time like correlate those things
for me personally as well it's been our
honor priv welcome again Marina thank
you so much it's great and do you have
any favorites in the the competitions
here I was glued to some games this
morning rooting for everyone El wow I
mean because in the Ladi section we're
just seeing something absolutely
extraordinary we have a 13-year-old now
I mean it's crazy Alice Lee and we're
very very proud of her and she's got a
cupcake that she's going to share with
me I mean I got that part of that's got
my name on it we were there for the
birthday song so it's it's pretty
incredible it's inspiring to see that
you know our youth can utilize their
mind and and their creativity and also
at the same time their passion for the
game absolutely thank you so much for
everything thank you for bringing kind
of Chess into the mainstream media
beautiful costumes Absolut oh I'm
excited who knew thank you thank you
very much for having me absolutely as we
uh take a look at our lady standings uh